self-awareness of your greatest
strengths self-awareness of your unique
difference in the marketplace
and don't i know you might even feel
insecure and you might have voices
saying
like i don't know if i have any
strengths you've got strengths but you
got to dig deep to refine them
have you ever thought about taking a
personality test to figure out what type
of youtube content creator you are
i am addicted to personality tests i've
taken all of them
and in this episode we're going to be
breaking down four
types of content creators that we see on
the platform
my name is heather torres and you are
listening to the think media podcast the
number one podcast
to help you grow your influence on
youtube and then
turn that influence into a high profit
and a high
impact business and if you're brand new
to this podcast
we want to welcome you this is where we
go deeper in the youtube knowledge
in youtube psychology and we really get
into the meat
of the mindset that goes into creating
great youtube
videos this is also brought to you by
our youtube
master class and i'll tell you more
about that after so if you're brand new
to what we're doing here i want to let
you know that your next step is probably
to take
our youtube class but sean cannell is
gonna get into
the heart of today's conversation as he
breaks down these four
different types of personalities and i
can't wait till after the episode to
talk through maybe
what kind of personality you have on the
channel
let's get into today's featured content
[Music]
have you ever taken a personality test
maybe you've taken the enneagram or the
myers-briggs or maybe you're on facebook
and it was like
learn your personality or you click
somewhere on the internet to take a test
to discover yourself
you know if you're curious and you know
any of those tests i discover that i'm
an enneagram
3 and an enfj
you know some famous enneagram threes
oprah madonna muhammad ali
elvis i'm not even sure what that means
but have you ever like looked like what
celebrity is like me in a personality
test
or enfj's jennifer lawrence come on
katniss everdeens
everdeens plural come on hunger games uh
morgan freeman king david how did they
even know that i mean i guess you
reverse engineered it from the bible to
figure out that king david was an enfj
but you know personality tests are so
popular
i started to ask the question what
personality traits
do you need to win on youtube have you
ever thought that like do i have what it
takes am i even wired to win
on youtube you know what are really the
stages of youtube success like the
progression
of maturing through our personality to
really win on youtube
and is it possible to actually even
change our personality develop the
necessary skills and step
into youtube success well in this
episode
i think it is possible and i want you to
listen till the end because
i have some new data to share with you
that will significantly speed up your
results
on youtube but i really want to talk
about these four different types of
youtube creators and my question for you
is which one are you
and which one are you becoming but
here's the first one here's the first
one
it's the it's uncommitted the
uncommitted youtube creator
now before you get mad like just just
listen this is this is what the un
committed youtube creator is
you're in a stage where you're a dreamer
that gets excited about the idea of
building a youtube channel
but you haven't truly committed can you
relate to that
i mean this i think we probably at one
point or another have all been in this
this place it depends on different areas
of life like i think about my
dream of having six-pack abs maybe it's
my wife sonia's dream but my dream
is to have six pack abs
i'm 37 now i've got an almost year-old
baby boy and i am fighting the dad bod
like so the six-pack abs they're just
not visible right now there's there's a
a thin i don't know how many inches
thick kind of tire that is surrounding
my midsection
as i'm entering into middle age
but the reality is like i have a dream
of having six-pack ad
abs but i'm not committed to it like
it's an idea
but i haven't really committed to it the
reality is
that a lot of us on youtube kind of stay
stuck
and we sort of stay in this season of
just being people who don't commit
and sometimes this could be an excuse
you're like you know i'm just the type
of person i have a lot of ideas but i
just never really commit
you know i have a lot of dreams but i
just never really commit you know that's
a choice
and you don't have to stay there so
listen
you cannot conquer what you're not
committed to
commitment is the foundation of all
great accomplishments commitment is what
turns
your dreams in to reality
so really we have to make a decision
that even if this is your proclivity i'm
just an idea person but i don't really
do a lot with the ideas
that we can change that we can evolve
past this and grow into
further stages of greater impact on
youtube ken blanchard said it this way
there's a difference between interest
and commitment
when you're interested in doing
something you only do it when it's
convenient but when you're committed to
doing something
you accept no excuses
only results listen if you really want
to get results
you got to commit and make a decision
that i'm not just interested in growing
a youtube channel
i'm committed to growing a youtube
channel so
what committed to what though i think we
have to make a decision that we're
committed to posting videos consistently
i think we have to make a decision that
we're committed to learning how youtube
works and studying youtube
we have to make a decision to developing
the fundamental skills
persisting when things get hard and
being patient because great things take
time ken blanchard man when you're
committed to something you accept no
excuses you
only accept results and you keep
persevering
but eventually we go into kind of season
two and maybe you can relate to being
this personality
when it comes to youtube you're like
sean i'm committed man
i've been posting consistently i am i'm
watching the think media podcast i'm
watching think media
i join video ranking academy i mean i'm
i'm
making steps i'm taking action well then
we kind of hit this second personality
type this second season
and it's the undisciplined youtube
creator
so at this point now you're getting some
results but you don't
invest the time and energy to create
momentum
like you're doing some things maybe even
getting some views but maybe you still
have some excuses like
i just don't have enough time there's
not enough time for me to do youtube
the truth is though of course you don't
have enough like nobody has
enough time did you know time is
actually the same for everybody we all
have the same 24 hours in a day
we don't have enough time we actually
have to make
time but that comes with a really
uncomfortable
swear word d word and that's the d word
discipline like when we hate that word
right youtube probably just censored me
for saying it
because like we don't actually want to
get disciplined
and actually take ownership to say
listen i'm not going to make excuses
i'm actually going to take
responsibility for my time
have you found yourself in this season
like you've made a commitment
to really grow your youtube channel to
maybe maybe your career has been
disrupted
maybe your income's been disrupted and
you see the opportunity and you even
know that you have it within you you
battle self-doubt but you do know that
this youtube thing is real
but you haven't really got disciplined
like when are you going to get
disciplined with your schedule
when are you going to get disciplined
with your choices
and choosing what to sacrifice the early
days of youtube especially
you're gonna have to sacrifice stuff you
might have to sacrifice some leisure you
might have to sacrifice some disney plus
oh sean don't go there you've just
touched the sacred mandalorian listen
loki we have to sometimes sacrifice
things
on the journey to success
you have to set goals and then commit to
making them happen
but discipline becomes the bridge
between your goals
and accomplishing them but hey if we
move past discipline
maybe you're like listen i'm kind of an
uncommitted person or actually i'm
committed but i'm kind of undisciplined
like i'm so scattered
eventually you overcome those first two
and now we enter number three which is
the unfocused
youtube creator and by the way
congratulations because
if you've committed you're like i'm all
in i'm going all in and if you're
disciplined you are doing the work
but this is a place where the majority
friend this is where i see most get
stuck
because you're chasing too many things
at once
the unfocused youtube creator i've
learned this this this youtube creator
they might have 100 000 subscribers
they might be generating five 10k 25 000
a month but they're actually really kind
of struggling
and stuck and can't break through the
plateau because
they're unfocused you know
i remember back to when i had a
full-time job
working at a church and i had a vision
to be building
my youtube channel and i wanted to make
an impact on youtube even as a side
hustle i enjoyed my job as well
but i was so unfocused i was doing too
many things at once and this season
you know i'm working full-time at a
church during the holidays especially
i'm making these gift ideas videos and
this is cool because i'm building some
side income but on my sean cannell
channel
i'm talking about like gift ideas for
him and her and gift ideas for
photographers and
making money through affiliate marketing
on youtube during this same time though
i'm writing an ebook and it's called get
noticed
and it's all about social media now that
might sound
like oh that seems like a good idea it
seems aligned no it wasn't aligned
i'm again full-time job i'm making gift
ideas videos but at the same time
i'm now talking about social media not
even youtube i'm writing an ebook
about every social media
platform in my opinion you can't
actually be that focused if you try to
talk about every social media platform
there's way too much detail in all the
different platforms
so i'm writing an e-book i'm making
videos full-time job i'm also trying to
build my email list
and writing an email newsletter to them
every week about what though like
they're downloading get noticed
i'm kind of trying to talk about youtube
i'm not even really focused
on youtube because i'm making gift ideas
videos
i'm sometimes covering tech on think
media and
these were the early days where i
started interviewing other youtube
creators and entrepreneurs with my
friend benji
on her channel video influencers friend
i was chasing too many things at once
and if i didn't get focused i would have
stayed stuck
in that season this third season is a
big one man you might just say oh it's
just my personality i just can't focus
you know squirrel that's me like no you
got to overcome that if you don't want
to stay stuck listen your personality
might be your natural proclivity
but with discipline you can overcome
that and you can say no i'm going to
choose to get focused i'm going to
choose to say no to some things
shiny objects social media a lack of
focus
keeps you stuck too many projects too
many channels
it's stunning how many times on heather
taurus's youtube made simple show on
the youtube podcast youtube channel or
on my show the coffee with kennel show
that people ask us when we do q a and
they say okay
so i have three youtube channel ideas
because
i know you told us to niche down so what
i'm gonna do is i think i'm gonna post
across
three different youtube channels so we
go okay well how much how consistent are
you being right now
well i'm only getting about three videos
up you know a week on my main channel
but what i'm really thinking about doing
is expanding because i
i'm just i'm so i'm multi-passionate
there's just so many things i'm
passionate about
listen it's hard enough to do one
youtube channel
why are you trying to do three and this
is coming out of my experience
of doing way too many youtube channels
and being
unfocused focus is a superpower
people ask they go okay we encourage you
someday
build an online course or write an ebook
turn your knowledge
into something that you can sell one of
the best ways to earn money in the
creator economy
but we hear people say they haven't
created one book they go i got three
ideas for the book i want to write and
i'm writing three books right now
dude that's unfocused like just write
one book and get it all the way to the
finish line
before you open up you know 14 different
projects
and i know you might be able to relate
to this and i don't mean to be stepping
all over your toes today and all up in
your business
but this will help you because you have
to make a decision to say even if your
personality proclivity
is to be unfocused you got to get
focused
and many successful youtube creators get
stuck here and they can't
really continue to scale because they're
doing too many things
i want to speak to you if you're not in
the starting season i want to speak to
you if you're making multiple six
figures a year
the key to getting to seven figures is
actually gonna be getting
focused and not doing more but it's
gonna be doing less
better you know there's a saying in navy
seals teams
smooth or slow is smooth smooth
is fast it's this idea that if you want
to move faster
slow down why so you don't make mistakes
so people don't get hurt so there isn't
a rush and a haste there's a proverb
haste makes mistakes smooth
slow is smooth smooth is fast
they underestimate that in combat in a
combat environment
feeling hurried and panicked can mean
death
the key to their success is their
ability to slow down
during stressful situations and act with
calm precision you want to win on
youtube
build your business build a high five
six figure seven figure business
if you want to move faster you should
slow down
get more focused have more calm
precision on the things that matter most
so how's your focus doing do you find
yourself in this season how's your
personal brand doing
is your personal brand focused or foggy
if somebody was to see you on social
media is it really clear who you are who
you help what you're about what you're
doing
is it focused or is it foggy are you
working on too many projects at once
do you need to set some things aside so
you can accomplish your most
important project first and next before
you open up
the door on other projects are you
wasting too much time on social media
here's the influencer dilemma because
it is easy for you to justify endlessly
scrolling on instagram
you're like dude i'm just doing market
research you know i just got i'm spying
on my competitors
no you're not you're procrastinating the
deep work you need to do
for actually building your youtube
channel
are you wasting too much time on social
media especially
if you really want to create
disproportionate impact in leverage on
youtube
social media may be helpful but it's
probably a distraction and you need to
figure out the shortest path to revenue
the shortest path to getting the youtube
algorithm working for you
so that you can scale up a team or
generate more revenue or create
systems or hire a va to help you with
social media
because if you're trying to chase two
rabbits you're gonna end up catching
neither of them
focus are you doing things
that take a lot of your time but deliver
literal results like when i got in this
ebook thing when i wrote my get noticed
ebook
like i'm spent all this time it was
actually by the way that was
inspired it was really actually a curse
not a blessing grateful that it happened
i suppose because you learned but it was
actually expired
inspired externally someone said hey can
you write a chapter for my book so i
spent all this time answering somebody
else's request
not focusing on a focused personal
vision
ended up writing this thing about social
media ended up then
turning that into like a shorter ebook
called get noticed
it took a lot of time it took a lot of
energy
then i thought i had to go deeper with
it so i started to build a newsletter
around it
then i had to fill you know continue to
follow up then i fought now and thought
now i have to cultivate this audience
and continue to serve this audience
about social media
meanwhile youtube is saying hey bro this
is your greatest strength
you've been doing video since 2003. you
don't need to be chasing 10
rabbits aka 10 social media platforms
how about you focus on youtube
and i was spending a lot of time but i
wasn't getting very good results
meanwhile our motto lately at think
media what can we stop doing
what can we say no to what is really
going to move the needle and what's
going to maybe take a lot of time but
not deliver a lot of results
if it's not going to deliver a lot of
results we're not going to do it 80 20
rule let's focus on where we have
disproportionate
leverage but listen there's a fourth
stage
kind of a four fourth personality type
which one are you and which one of these
can you relate to the most
being the uncommitted youtube creator
the undisciplined community youtube
creator
the unfocused youtube creator or the
fourth level
which is the unstoppable youtube creator
man when you get committed and you say
i'm gonna go all in when you get
disciplined
and you start saying i'm not gonna make
excuses for my schedule i'm not gonna
say i don't have enough time
i'm going to manage my time i'm going to
make my i'm going to set my priorities
i'm going to choose my focus
when you stack all of these up you
become unstoppable
and the goal here is to be developing an
unstoppable
skill set the reason you're unstoppable
is at this point you understand how
youtube works
so you know what content to create you
know how to get views
consistently and the youtube algorithms
working for you you know how to make
money
consistently because you've taken the
time to set up proven income streams
or to set up a proven business model or
to do the hard work
of finishing the book that is really
going to move the needle
or the course that is really going to
move the needle or the
online challenge that you're gonna do
four times a year
or whatever vehicle that you get
disciplined on
and instead of chasing every shiny
object and you're like i'm building a
quiz funnel
why i'm running a seven day challenge
and i'm doing two new webinars and i'm
writing three free
ebooks and i'm writing two full-length
ebooks and i'm trying to set up my first
live event and i'm also
i have 10 hours a week to do this
because of my full-time job
you got to get focused but when you
figure out on what's going to make money
consistently and you get those proven
paths of revenue going now
you're unstoppable and you can start to
scale the unstoppable skill set is
developing self-awareness
it's realizing like i had to realize
i don't need to be talking about every
social media platform why did i even
write this get noticed on social media
ebook
when i should have been writing youtube
secrets which came
later self-awareness of your greatest
strengths self-awareness of your unique
difference in the marketplace
and don't i know you might even feel
insecure and you might have voices
saying
like i don't know if i have any
strengths you've got strengths but you
got to dig deep to refine them
i don't know if i even have a voice to
share you have a voice
and your message matters but you got to
dig deep and do the work to refine that
and and lean into your self-awareness
that becomes your unstoppable
skill set you've got to find a proven
and a profitable niche
that aligns with your strengths and that
might mean
that you pivot your plan pivot your
channel because when you get into the
right
place on youtube align with your passion
and your proficiency
proficiency and your profit that's an
unstoppable place to be
but there's also not just the
unstoppable skill set there's the
unstoppable mindset
your purpose and your conviction with
this mindset
are stronger than your critics come on
because as you continue to succeed
you can get undisciplined and distracted
and unfocused because you start
listening to the critics more
than your own conviction your critics
and the people that are raising their
voices in your comment section
are shouting louder at you than your
purpose come on your purpose
and your conviction need to be stronger
than your critics
that's the unstoppable mindset you have
a mission that's bigger than your
feelings
yeah like when you're in the unstoppable
mindset see i don't feel like filming
today
see i don't feel like doing the hard
work see i feel
like my back hurts i feel like i'm
dealing with
some emotional fatigue i don't feel
good today but my mission is so
strong to help people and solve problems
and help them reach their ambitions
that i'm able to overcome my feelings
and not just sink into
uncommitment or being undisciplined if
you have an unstoppable mindset you've
mastered your moods and you've mastered
your self-talk
if you have an unstoppable mindset you
believe that everything is figureoutable
even if it takes me a year two three
four five years it's figureoutable
and i will until i don't think these
this mindset comes from a momentary this
isn't an overnight mindset
but this is what you build into to get
yourself out of uncommitment
and out of being undisciplined and out
of being unfocused so that you enter
into being
unstoppable so the question is
are these personality types a curse or
are they an invitation to a choice
because some would say you know sean
that might be easy to you
you for you to say genetically you were
born with an unstoppable mindset well
number one i'll tell you that's not true
number two that is a vulnerability for
you to make that observation
because that is giving away your
personal power
choosing to just stay in a disempowered
state where nothing is changeable
but what's crazy is it's not even based
in real psychology or real science
so i got two stories for you the first
is i was at dave ramsey's
studio recently in studio it's like a
empire it's a massive four-story
building they're building a second
building
300 million dollar cash they paid for
the building of course because no credit
right
and a thousand employees at this dave
ramsey
headquarters ramsey solutions we got to
hang out with the entree leadership team
so we were learning a little bit about
leadership about how they build their
team about how they make revenue about
the mistakes
the unfocused seasons they were in the
different seasons where they were
getting clarity
and really figuring out their
unstoppable tip of the spear for the
impact they want to make
building leaders of course ramsay wants
to help people get out of debt
but entree leadership specifically where
we were having like a two hour like deep
dive kind of mastermind thing they were
speaking into us all about leadership
and we got into the topic of hiring
the question came up when you're hiring
people do you have them go through
personality tests
and they said yeah you know we do we
have them do the myers-briggs we have a
new enneagram everybody does them
you know some people even have these
little like uh like little things on
their desk that lets you know when you
approach them you see what their
personality type is okay so i know a
little bit about their proclivities and
we said okay
okay so personality tests are a big deal
then whether or not you're gonna hire a
person and they go no
actually they don't matter we go what
they go yeah it actually doesn't matter
what we've learned
is actually that just personal maturity
and responsibility supersedes no matter
what they score on their personality
test
we go what yeah that like personality
tests are cute
like they're like they they give you
maybe some insights about who you are
but it's actually the person's maturity
saying maybe i'm naturally uncommitted
but i can make a choice to actually
become a person of commitment
and so they have risen above whatever
they scored
on the enneagram or the myers-briggs or
the strength finder or whatever your
favorite personality test is
and what's crazy second story is i've
been recently reading a book called
personality isn't permanent and actually
that the science
and real psychology has revealed that in
fact your personality
is changeable of course you're born
with certain traits and of course you're
born with uniqueness that will stick
with you for probably most of your life
but did you know that you can make a
choice
to rise above the weaknesses in your
personality
first of all personality tests aren't
even based on science
they're not they're not they've never
been based on science
did you know that the personality test
is a multi-billion dollar industry
when in doubt follow the money you know
what i mean like so and they keep making
new ones because peop we just love like
ooh
a new personality test i'm going to
discover things about me and i want you
to
i'm not hating on personality tests i
think they're cool it's great that like
uh king david and i are the same
myers-briggs if that's even a thing
but but ultimately they're just an
indicator
they don't have to be a dictator of
where you stay stuck
on your journey on youtube because you
might be saying sean i can't be that
unstoppable person
you can because your personality isn't
permanent
the book's benjamin hardy and of course
we always that's the author we always
link up re resources
in the show notes and i highly recommend
it but listen to what dr
catherine rogers says i wouldn't trust
the myers-briggs test to tell me any
more about my personality
then i would trust my horoscope
shots fired listen like whatever your
your beliefs or your background is but
again if you're giving away your
personality
your personal power to a personality
test it might be your decision
to stay stuck your score on a
personality test
did not reveal your true and authentic
self
and that's what ramsay was saying by the
way this is not some like
fledgling startup that you know has
hired one person and started business
coaching
they got a thousand people they got
coaches coaching other businesses
tens of thousands of businesses and
they're like yeah we've learned
that person and personality tests are
cool as a way of kind of getting to know
somebody
but that their maturity supersedes the
test
by a factor of 100x the personality test
is inconsequential and no matter what
they score
it's going to be based on how that
person responds to setbacks how that
person chooses to be self-aware
of what their proclivities are but to
make mature decisions
to actually overcome their natural bent
and here's what we've learned as we land
the plane on the podcast
that the frameworks that we've
experienced from our video ranking
academy
the frameworks of our book youtube
secrets the principles
we've learned the principles work at
this point
we have observed in just our company not
even the people we work with and our
friends and other peers
just inside of think media that people
of
all ages introverts and
extroverts gen z and
baby boomers people from every different
color
background and ethnicity people from
every different niche every different
technical skill level
every different proclivity and bent have
succeeded with the principles
we teach we can give examples of of
every different type of person
countless students have passed
through these levels so the question for
you
is are you gonna stay in the excuse of
sean or my personality as i'm just
uncommitted
my personality you know what i just
can't get disciplined i'm just i'm just
i'm just one of those people i'm so
creative i always got like 30 projects
going it's just me you know i always
i always got okay or you could stop
doing
29 of those projects and get a project
done
that's more of a choice than it is a
curse
of your personality so i want to
encourage you to make a decision today
i'm going to get committed
i'm going to get disciplined i'm going
to get focused
and i'm going to build the skill sets
necessary to become unstoppable
it's a choice to set a goal and don't
just take my word for it
read the book benjamin hardy phd
new science packed with examples
of the fact that personality isn't
permanent but purpose is greater than
personality
having a vision is greater than
personality and making a
choice is greater than personality and i
want you to
to know that i believe in you here at
think media we believe in you and we
want to help you on this
journey of building the unstoppable
skill sets
and mindsets necessary for building a
high impact
and a high profit youtube channel and an
online business
around that that changes the world
well did you identify what type of
content creator you are
are you uncommitted or undisciplined or
unfocused or
are you unstoppable when i look at these
different stages
i can see my journey through youtube
through these stages
i was undisciplined i was unfocused i
was uncommitted but now
i feel like i'm in that stage of being
unstoppable
you know when it comes to the journey of
youtube it's okay
to work through these different stages
it's okay if you feel like
man i'm really in that undisciplined
time right now
and i really just need to figure out
what i am doing maybe you're unfocused
and you're like i need to get my
calendar right
well here on the think media podcast we
have episodes for you
on this so i recommend going back into
our library
and binging as much of this content as
you can
you know for us here at think media it
is so awesome to
get to read your comments every single
week and to see you sharing
this podcast out on social media now if
you rate and review the podcast
over on apple itunes we can see it and i
can share one with you
here on the podcast and today's comes
from sordis
sorties says thankful think media exists
me too sorties i'm thankful think media
exists
the think media team is truly world
class at providing us content creators
which with as much value as possible
i'm extremely grateful to have found
them and look forward to continue
growing as a professional as well as an
individual
i really love their approach when
teaching us different techniques
in vra which is video ranking academy
before we even get to the meat of the
course
sean touches on the mindset at the end
of the day your
perception of things and the right
mindset
is what will help you succeed to think
media this is just
as important as providing good content i
love you guys
thanks so much for a great podcast as
well we're stylids thank you for leaving
such an amazing comment and i read these
every single week it brings me so much
joy to see
that this podcast is bringing you value
and i love that you touched on the
mindset part because that's what we want
to do here on the podcast
we want to go deeper in the areas of
mindset and
how you really truly can get success on
youtube yeah it's about the tactics yes
it's about the thumbnails
yes it's about getting good titles but
really when it comes down to it
it comes down to the right mindset of
being a content creator
well this episode is brought to you by
our think
master class have you taken the free
youtube class yet if you've not taken it
i highly recommend that after this
episode
you schedule some time on your calendar
to go to thinkmasterclass.com
that's where you're going to get a 45
minute intense training with sean
cannell where he's going to be diving
into how to succeed on youtube
the three secrets of youtube and what's
holding you back and your next step if
you're ready to dive deeper with us
here at think media i want to thank you
so much for your time today
thank you for listening to this podcast
and i would love if you would share this
with a friend
maybe you have a youtube buddy that you
uh are accountable with
maybe you know someone who should be
starting a youtube channel
send them this podcast or share one of
our other episodes that we have here
and we would love to see that on social
media thank you so much for your time
today and we'll catch you in the next
episode
you